my blood could save a life but instead
it's over here boiling Andy Cohen is
calling out the FDA in a big way
after recovering from coronavirus I
wanted to see if there was something
that I could do to help people who were
infected back in March the Bravo host
announced on Instagram that he tested
positive for the corona virus I am
feeling a lot better and I am so eager
just to get back to doing what we do
best here at watch what happens live now
that he's recovered he wants to find a
way to help others who are suffering but
on Thursday's episode of watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen he revealed
that when he signed up to donate plasma
he was deemed ineligible due to his
sexual orientation I was told that due
to antiquated and discriminatory
guidelines by the FDA to prevent HIV
I am ineligible to donate blood because
I'm a gay man even the new relaxed rules
require gay men to abstain from sex for
three months whether they're in a
monogamous relationship or not before
giving blood though no such blanket
restrictions exist for people of other
sexual orientations
Andy noted that screening donated blood
for HIV is easy-peasy and shouldn't be
an excuse to discriminate all donated
blood is screened for HIV and a rapid
HIV test can be done in 20 minutes or
less
so why the three-month rule why are
members from my community being excluded
from helping out when so many people are
sick and dying maybe because we're
valuing stigma over science I don't know
then Andy made a pretty compelling
please my blood could save a life but
instead it's over here boiling this
pandemic has forced us to adapt in many
ways we're quarantine amor social
distancing we're wearing masks
why can't we adapt when it comes to this
rule it is bad enough the quarantine has
us wondering what day it is I'm sitting
here wondering what year it is and it
turns out Andy is just one of men
being turned away if I were a you know a
viable candidate the I wanted to help I
just want to help Good Morning America
shared 36 year old Lucas East ox story
on Friday he says he passed in New York
City blood bank questionnaire and the
hospital told him he was a prime
candidate but when it came time to
donate Lucas was shocked by what he
heard when he told them he was gay you
will not be donating today Lucas hit up
Facebook to write about the whole thing
and it's since gone viral quote I've
rarely felt as embarrassed or angry or
defeat it as I did last week being told
that the still too uncommon health I'm
able to offer during a global crisis is
unwelcome simply because of Who I am in
this city in New York City in 2020 we
need to think about this and do better
[Music]